the Houston Texans head coach Bill
O'Brien kind enough to call in to the
show on a Friday afternoon after OTAs
are in the books how are you coach
Goodrich thanks for having me on how you
doing I am doing great I'm hosting
without a knee brace today so I'm
feeling really good coach I'm light
years ahead I'm light years ahead right
now brace doctor told you you were good
to go today without a knee brace that's
good well I got to tell you I'm sitting
here in Los Angeles and I hear that news
that DeShawn's not using a knee brace
and I I just I winced myself I wonder
what it feels like to be the coach of
this kid when that's happening
ya know he uh you know I think he's come
a long way obviously he unfortunately he
he had injured knee at Clemson and and
at the same time though it gave him in
this instance a chance to really
understand what went into the rehab and
I think that he's along with our medical
team have really done a good job of
bringing him along at a good pace but
not a rushed pace and I think towards
the end of minicamp here he was able to
come out there and and do some things
without the brace you know I think
that's a that's a good sign and he's had
a really he's had a really good spring
force do you think he's gonna have that
practice in games this fall no knee
brace out there in the fall I think time
will tell rich I don't you know again I
don't really I don't know that right now
I would say that that would be something
that we'll evaluate when we when we get
back here for training camp I'm not sure
that I'd be able to answer that clearly
right now so the one thing and at times
that I've gotten to meet your
quarterback and deshaun Watson he's such
a good person such a good kid I mean
just everything about him you know
watching him on his first start on
Thursday night Cincinnati when he ran
that one in from midfield and just
seeing him succeed like this I mean what
does he like to be around and around his
teammates coach yeah I think what you
see is exactly right I mean he's really
a a very down-to-earth guy very very
smart really enjoys being around his
teammates he's got a really
you know just a neat presence about him
you know he's calm he's poised and I
think he's he's a lot of fun to coach
every day and obviously you know with
the talent and all those things
obviously but it's just it's more than
that it's it's an ability to go into a
meeting room and and know that you have
a guy that's looking for knowledge but
also a guy that's gonna have some really
good input into what you're doing is
he's got a good mind for football and
it's been it's been fun to coach him
what can he improve upon well you know I
think there's a lot I mean I think I
think that there's so many things that
come with experience rich you know I
think the more he plays and the more he
sees the more he'll he'll be able to
improve I think this this spring we were
able to improve in a lot of different
areas you know obviously knowledge of
our offense knowledge of defense and
then he was able to do some things out
on the field like we talked about
earlier and in this conversation he was
able to go out there and do some seven
on seven and and individual drills and I
think that really helped them
mechanically to be able to to improve on
something so I think he's that he's the
guy that will tell you right away that
he's trying to get 1% better every day
and that's what you're looking for and
in that position Bill O'Brien Texas head
coach joining us here on the Rich Eisen
show how is JJ Watt doing good good he's
uh you know he's had a really good
office League Denise he's rehabbed I
know that he feels really good about
where he's at
he's just been a really excellent leader
for us he's been here every day really
committed to what we're trying to do
here and we're all looking forward to
him being back it's just amazing what
he's become to coach I mean this yeah
this guy could run from there right now
I imagine I mean that mayor yeah that's
right governor no I'm kidding I'm
kidding I just think that he's done so
much for the community I mean you know
you think about hurricane Harvey
obviously that was incredible
what he was able to raise money wise and
what he's doing with that money is
incredible but I think it's even more
than that he really he really is
invested in this community he does a lot
for
for four kids he does a lot for the food
bank of Houston he does a lot for a lot
of different areas in Houston tonight I
think he's uh he's obviously been a huge
part of this city for a long time Casa
Jaime and clown he's doing what do you
think about him good I think he's I
think he's on the way back I think you
know I think he's a guy that understands
what he needs to do to be ready to go
for training camp he's told me that
he'll be ready to go for training camp
and you know last year was the first
year that he was able to play a 16-game
season which is really good it's a big
accomplishment for him because you know
previous years the injuries kind of held
him back and he was able to show
everybody what he could do last year in
16 games so you know I think I think
it's important for him to be ready to go
on July 25th and he's he's guaranteed me
that he will be oh my my longtime
colleague Pro Football Hall of Famer
Warren Sapp always tells me the front
and the back of the defense have to be
play together they're connected and now
you got a really good one Tyrann Mathieu
back there how does he fit in to this
program
he's been somebody that we were really
excited to be able to add to our roster
and when he you know for the nine week
offseason program he's been here every
day and he's really an impressive guy
he's knowledgeable about football he's a
really good teammate and he's he's he's
shown up on the field quite a bit he's a
he's a good player he understands the
scheme he's got good leadership
qualities we're really excited about
having him on our team I mean I didn't
even mentioned DeAndre Hopkins I'm
telling you coach the expectation is sky
high for your team there's no question
about that how do you handle that well
you know I think I think that that one
of the things that this team really
prides itself on is competing in
practice and you know putting in the
work every day and I think as long as we
all understand that that we just
continue to try to get better you know
that's what it is rich it's there should
be high expectations you know really for
every team you know I think that's what
this league is all about but I also
think that it's a progress league it's
an improvement league and we have to
really understand hey here are things
that eat them every day we've got to
come out
get better at and I think we've got a
group of guys that understand that yeah
I know it's just that it is though a
world where you know social media and
everybody hears everything about
everything I mean Deshawn even retweeted
somebody who thought that he wasn't
gonna come back blah blah blah I mean
how do you as a head coach a tune out
the noise obviously you were around a
guy in Belichick who could you know put
the velvet ropes around any situation
and suck the oxygen out of any media
scenario but how do you do that yeah I
think I think that one of the things as
a head coach you know this is actually
for me between Penn State and here it's
I'm going into my seventh year as a head
coach and I think every year you you
have to understand how much whether it's
social media or any other thing outside
of football that these guys are involved
in or have opinions on is that that's
important to them that's that's
something that you have to you have to
understand about their lives and what's
important to them but but at the same
time when they enter into the building
when they when they enter into what
you're asking them to do you have to do
the best job you can of keeping them
focused and understanding like hey this
is what's important and just don't worry
about this extraneous stuff and focus on
the things that you have to do to get
better and I think as long as you keep
talking about that and emphasizing those
things I think guys guys will stay
focused Bill O'Brien a few more minutes
here at the Texans head coach on the
Rich Eisen show you mentioned Penn State
I'd be remiss if I didn't say that
Christian Hackenberg is sitting there as
a free agent right now a kid who had
such a huge future certainly when you
had him for that season while you were
there together in the middle of the
great state of Pennsylvania Jon Gruden
said that the the organized team
activity and the offseason set up with
the collective bargaining agreement
prevents people in this league from
cultivating quarterbacks would you agree
with that sent sentiment and that's
what's going on with Hackenberg I have a
strong belief rich that that we need to
be able to spend more time with young
players at every position especially
quarterbacks I think that
it takes a while to develop a
quarterback the difference in pro
football relative to college football is
huge you know it's different schemes
obviously a faster game different rules
different field dimensions it takes a
while to figure out all the things that
it takes to play quarterback in this
league and I think that back even when I
started coaching in the NFL you know you
had quarterback school you know that
started like the middle of March
you know like can we have a couple extra
weeks to be able to work with these
quarterbacks especially obviously like I
said the first second-year guys to be
able to at least get them in the meeting
room maybe do some things out on the
field but at the very least give us some
some some more time to help develop them
I think that's a big deal and I do I do
agree with John on that something you
talked to Bob McNair about you talked to
him about this because that's that's the
guy you need to that I imagine this is
what's coming down the pike and part and
parcel of a collective bargaining
conversation in a few it is it is and
it's something that I always you know
you know Bob and I talk all the time
about the different things that are
going on in the NFL and that's
definitely something that you know that
we've we've talked about you know having
come to a resolution on what what what
exactly our you know in fact plan would
be our idea for maybe a little bit more
time with some of these younger players
but I do think when the next CBA comes
up I would love to see you know just a
little bit more time given to like what
I'm saying rich the younger players I
don't think you know I'm not necessarily
saying that the ten year vet
you know right after the season ends all
the way through till the middle of June
but I do think the younger players the
at every position especially quarterback
maybe we could spend a little bit more
time with them on the new CBA comes out
Bill O'Brien Texans head coach you're on
the show I appreciate you calling and
you get some personal time you do yeah
well I have little league baseball for a
while we got a lot of baseball down here
in Texas so I got a little little league
baseball and then maybe a little
vacation on the East Coast
now when you say little league baseball
are you the coach of this tonight no no
I am a fan I sit out in the right field
and watch
a thirteen-year-old son he just turned
13 it's a 12 year old team but I watch
him pitch and play first base and hit
and it's fun to watch his team okay do
you get on the UMP do you get on the oh
no no rich you never you're not
helicoptering at all I'm not a
helicopter dad I'm out there and in the
outfield trying to stay away from the
fray okay well I'd like for you to help
me with one last thing if you don't mind
there's a little personal time for me
here I have a seven-year-old okay yep
I have a seven-year-old who was uh he's
in a pitch League and another
seven-year-old hit him with a pitch
right in the rows I mean right in the
ribs he goes down in a heap he starts
crying so I jump out I'm just I'm just
the dad I'm not the coach there I am in
my civilian clothes okay I jump out
there to see if he's okay and then I
tell him to go back and hit because he
waits all week to hit coach he waits all
week to hit and I say do not take your
face go in hit and the umpire says you
got to take your base I I said something
to the UMP I said you know he's been
waiting all week to hit and the UMP like
no but I've got to follow the rules he's
got to take his base and that's when I
departed back to my seat did I do
something wrong did I did I handle this
inappropriately no I think you I think
you have the right idea but it's the
rules of the game HBP you got to take
first base hit by pitch you got to go
the first base that's the rules but you
know I understand what you're saying and
you know maybe maybe we could talk to
the little league about you know
changing that rule but what are you
gonna do he had to take his base did he
get up again
he did he did get up again you know he
he grounded one to the left side and he
beat it out because he's got the
heartbeat of a champion you know you can
get riled up sometimes I see you on the
sidelines so I got me that's not me no
I'm very calm it's fun it's fun with the
Little League baseball though it's
really in Texas it's everyday there's a
game every day so it's a lot of fun to
follow but I try to I try to stay out in
the
filled or not not entering too much yeah
no they know that's that's the coach of
the Texans you can't see now I see what
you're saying now you got a gift to keep
it'll down on the down low I hear you
all right coach enjoy your personal time
let's chat as the season progresses okay
Chris thank you that's a Bill O'Brien at
Houston Texans the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience